from romantic kisses to battery acid as
it turns out almost anything can be
dangerous when it comes to costuming
we're looking at 15 times actors felt
like they were suffocating in their suit
number one who gave dano the green light
to wrap his head in cling film yes you
heard that correctly paul dano actually
wrapped his face in cling wrap for the
batman film his logic being that the
riddler would have no way to leave any
dna at a crime scene just an hour into
filming he was seeing lights but he
didn't want to tell anyone because it
was the first day on set and he didn't
want to be the actor complaining about a
headache on day one i just start to see
whites and colors and my brain is
he found himself googling things like
brain swelling while lying in bed that
night you can't sweat that's the issue
the next day they poked some holes in
the cling wrap and it solved all of his
problems pro tip mention it on day one
you can waste a whole lot more time
reshooting if you gotta change things
number two not that we know much about
the creepy crawlers but we're pretty
sure spiders don't drink through their
eyes tom holland has always struggled
with his spidey suit and has been the
most vocal about it too taking off the
mask is too much work so when he needs a
drink he just gets somebody to pop out
his eye sockets this is a concern for
zendaya who worries about what would
happen if her boyfriend vomited inside
the mask that is air tight and
complicated to remove this is a genuine
concern apparently it's a whole process
to take the mask and helmet off and it
takes assistance
number three robs really come full
circle from sparkly vampire to gothic
bat huh robert pattinson equated the
batman suit to almost torture
the whole thing was incredibly
uncomfortable the cowl makes its own
expressions and it has nothing to do
with the performance you're giving it's
more like puppeteering than anything you
can have all the ideas in the world
about how you want to play a character
and then you put the suit on and
it's just straight back to the drawing
board
number four the itsy bitsy spidey went
up the water spout down came the rain
and washed the spidey out andrew
garfield accidentally waterboarded
himself in his suit he'd stated i had to
get wet and i just kind of dove in and
did not realize that water on the mask
made it impossible to breathe so i was
kind of like suffocating i could not get
any oxygen i waterboarded myself luckily
his fight coordinator andy armstrong saw
how much garfield was struggling and
jumped in to get him out of the mask
immediately number five imagine being
stuck in an 88 pound suit immersed in an
unknown goo after over six hours in a
makeup chair
problematically an entire suit was
wasted in filming because it was buoyant
once immersed in the oil slash water
slash whatever else garsgard had to sit
in
so they had to poke holes all over the
thing to stop him from floating adding
to the weight of the costume was a
hidden cooling vest that was attached to
a portable refrigerator system this
saved him from having a stroke
number 6. turns out hollywood's most
romanticized kiss was a total nightmare
for toby during that steamy kissing
scene with kirsten you know the one
upside down in the rain director sam
raimi recalls water running into toby's
upside down nostrils and that he was
kind of drowning raymie said but it was
a kissing scene so he had to pretend
like it was a pleasant sweet moment for
him when in fact he was semi-drowning
number seven you could say david was
harboring bad feelings towards his
costume david harbor who played the
namesake character hellboy in the reboot
said the costume felt like a coffin and
said coffin gets really hot and
claustrophobic and then like i would get
freaked out getting the face of hellboy
on took about two hours the blending of
the eye where the latex ends that's all
like really hard stuff to do number
eight you could say the horror crux of
rafe's decision making came down to
discomfort after playing voldemort rafe
hated the makeup process so much because
it was so uncomfortable and he
considered turning down other movies
with such extensive makeup processes
luckily for rafe it was the visual
effects artist playing got your nose
with him and not the makeup artists
number nine
you can't itch a scratch and you can't
scratch an itch either for jessica do
you know what the part was that bothered
her the most about playing tammy fay it
was the itching the insatiable itching
because you truly can't scratch that
itch in costume you can't dig your nails
under the prosthetics and just give it a
good go it would be enough to drive a
person mad
number 10. perhaps karen was feeling a
bit nebulous in her costume karen plays
nebula in the mcu it's just a feeling of
like claustrophobia she felt that way
because she was completely enclosed
comparing it to a second skin that's
glued to her face she finds it to be a
weird sensation because the prosthetic
stopped her from being able to express
normally it was a blessing in disguise
though because she found the inability
to move much stopped her from overacting
number 11. this mask was the bane of
tom's existence bane's mask in the dark
knight rises was super freaking tight
and made morgan freeman and gary oldman
question just how fun it could possibly
be for tom hardy to wear all the time
and they found that the thing was very
claustrophobic hardy had said of it i
had something to moan about legitimately
number 12 this sweat is boldly going
where no sweat has ever gone before
oscar isaac found himself to be
perspiring in the weirdest of places
during filming for x-men apocalypse the
sweat was literally pouring into his
ears and there was absolutely nothing he
could do about it imagine not being able
to touch your brain with a cotton swab
anytime you've got a slight ear itch
he admitted i didn't know when i said
yes that that was what was going to be
happening that i was going to be encased
in glue latex and a 40-pound suit that i
had to wear a cooling mechanism at all
times i couldn't move my head ever
number 13 the 90s were a wild time
remember eating batteries yeah us
neither arnold schwarzenegger played mr
freeze in the 1997 movie batman and
robin what's so notable about his
costume was that he had an led light in
his mouth which looked cool when he
spoke however problematically the
actor's saliva would seep into the
batteries and the batteries would leak
acid into his mouth talk about
disgusting and dangerous
number 14. at least buddy has a good
excuse for why he dusted his body with
toxic materials it was a simpler time
another even older movie of note was the
wizard of oz buddy ebsen was originally
slated to play tin man however the
makeup he wore for the role turned out
to be toxic aluminum dust he wound up in
the hospital and was eventually replaced
by jack haley
number 15. ninjas are supposed to be
quick and light on their feet nobody
thought this through for the live action
and one more nostalgic film the 1990s
teenage mutant ninja turtles movie had a
total of four actors feeling incredibly
claustrophobic in their suits they
weighed about 48 pounds each and once
the helmets were on you couldn't get
them off because the actors would need
to get rewired into their costumes which
would take around a half hour despite
these downright horrendous experiences
the actors deal with most of them would
probably take on the role again except
for maybe he who shall not be named what
suit would you be willing to deal with
to play the role let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things